Film Courage: So on a movie like A CHILD’S
VOICE, where do you spend the most money?
John Paul Rice, Film Producer: Well cast,
crew and all the logistics, locations and
food and equipment and insurance.
Like it goes into the personnel, it’s all
the below-the-line, but not for us.
It’s a labor of love at that point.
Our stuff is not to pay ourselves (that’s
just me) but all of it goes into the planning,
the implementation and also what I try to
do is look at the budget every couple of days
and start to try to figure out where I can
get donations, where I can get discounts,
where I can smartly schedule things so that
we’re not spending double money to get the
same thing that we could if we plan it better
or smartly write it in a way that doesn’t
require…because you’ve just got to look
at what you’re trying to say.
What are you trying to say with this scene
(with each scene)?
Do we really need to stretch it out or can
we consolidate here (maybe combine something).
So it’s a team effort between me and Edgar
[Edgar Michael Bravo].
But mine are always to try to find things
that are reducing cost and overhead every
single time.
Film Courage: Well you had the hotel [that
they shot scenes in for A CHILD’S VOICE].
Was that somewhere in Riverside [CA]?
John: It was in Riverside.
Film Courage: Okay so it would be cheaper
than somewhere in LA I’m sure?
John: Right and Riverside is cheaper to film
and you still have to do all the permits and
everything.
You still have to do everything else but it’s
not expensive.
It’s gone up in the last couple of years
because they have more filming out there now.
But the county of Riverside is fantastic.
Those two women who run it are fantastic.
As long as they’re there they will do really,
really well.
The City of Riverside is independent of that
but the County of Riverside opens you up to
so many other things.
They have location service that they will
help you with.
We went to seven or eight hotels in different
groups and I drove out there and I lobbied
all of them.
Film Courage: What’s that like?
John: It’s difficult.
You’re going to meet a lot of people who
don’t care but some people when you talk
to them and you tell them what you’re doing
and what you’re about and the realities
of what you’re dealing with…I’m dealing
with a crew of eight people, this many actors
coming in, I need this kind of room, can you
help us out?
We had help, we would not have been able to
make the film if we had not taken out more
money and away from something else potentially
where I would have to raise some later if
it wasn’t for that manager at that particular
hotel who gave us a discount because he was
personally invested in that issue and you
never know how things are going to come.
But that came from the relationship with his
brother who knew the person who had endorsed
their previous film in a letter of writing
just so happen he knew who he was.
Told these guys “Yeah, whatever they’re
doing if they’re backed by this guy, you
help them out whatever you can.”
But it was who he was (the owner) and the
heart that he had for this issue.
He came all the way out from Riverside with
his family and his mother and father to the
premiere and continued to help us afterward
by taking us into this hotel association (Asian
American Hotel Owners Association) no one
knows about this, 18,000 members, one out
of every two hotels in the country.
And one of their core tenants of what they’re
fighting against is human trafficking in their
chains and they have a program (this is like
a top program) where all of their members
have to receive training from the tops down
all the way housemaids on how to correctly
identify the signs of, how to document it
and how to get local law enforcement and local
government services involved to get it out
of there and still help them.
Because the life is in danger once they know
that they’re there trafficking in that…because
they may go somewhere else but they may do
something else, more crime may come in.
So these are the things when you connect with
people, because of what you’re driven by,
you speak truthfully to that and I saw a couple
people that no matter what I said to them
I just saw…
Film Courage: The lights were out?
John: They were like “Uh huh.
Sure.
Okay.
We’ll talk.”
And you don’t hear anything else.
So it’s like a day or two or three that
I had to go out there, talk and meet people
and leave cards and follow-up.
But but you’re talking about a hundred something
dollars a night per room versus less which
enables you do more with your budget and your
crew and maybe add a day or whatever or you
don’t have to worry about “How the hell
am I going to pay for this?”
It’s really valuable to go out there as
a producer that’s what I love to do.
I’m a hands on guy.
I like to get involved with everything, the
locations, all of it.
Some people try to…there’s this one guy
Mark Stoloraff (I love the guy) he’s like
“Beg, Barter and Steal.”
Right?
And to me it’s like “Okay, well I’d
rather not steal.
And I don’t want to beg.
But I definitely want to align myself with
people who like what we do.
Film Courage: Right.
Like a Grateful Dead concert “Hey man, you
can have my spaghetti if I can get this.”
John: Exactly!
Film Courage: The thing is I bet you can probably
see in the ones that do show some signs of
life like this person is going to be easy
to work with?
Whereas with others it’s all about the dollar
signs you can just feel that…”Hey we’re
going to need to run an hour late?”
Was that some of what you were dealing with,
gauging their willingness?
John: Yeah because if this was the starting
point right?
This was what I was mentioning earlier about
being fixated on a person or an idea or a
way that you want to do it you just have to
adapt and be like “That’s not who they
are” and save yourself the trouble because
anything after that you’re going to have
to be asking them permission to do all sorts
of things and what you want to do is (not
to hide if from them) but you want to partner.
You want somebody who understands like when
we wanted to write that additional scene (the
pool scene)?
Film Courage: The one at night?
John: We came up with that while we were filming
and he said “Yeah, go for it!”
We didn’t have to sit there and negotiate
something with them.
He’s like “You guys do whatever you need
to do.”
We didn’t have to sit there and negotiate
something with them.
They were just like “Yeah, you guys do whatever
you need to do.”
They loved us.
They loved seeing the film.
We brought them into the room and let the
watch the filming.
Of course they get bored after 20 minutes.
That’s how everybody does.
They are like “Oh?
This is it?”
“Yeah, this is it.”
But making them a part of it and showing them
appreciation.
We put their name in the credits as a very
special thanks and it’s just as a gesture.
And you put a gesture out and someone will
give you a gesture back.
It may not be everything that you want or
envisioned for your movie but work with those
people because they’re going to be there
when things don’t go right the way you planned
it and you may need something else and you
may need something else that you didn’t
anticipate or something that comes up and
they were just so giving with us.
It was really a great thing.